mes amours on va parler des questions de
santé hein justement ça ça fait la
transition alors ça ça sera peut-être un
facteur encore aggravant mais l'état de
l'hôpital aujourd'hui Frédéric valtrous
est-ce que nos hôpitaux sont prêts à
affronter l'été qui arrive
c'est une question que qui est légitime
qui est normal et qu'effectivement
chaque été ou chaque début d'été on se
pose et on a raison de se la poser parce
que l'hôpital est très fragile depuis
des années et je veux dire les les les
les mots de l'hôpital se sont pas
résolus en ces derniers mois n'ont pas
que il se passe rien pour essayer de
résoudre mais c'est que les choses ne
s'inverseront pas aussi facilement que
ça on a claquement de doigt le principal
problème c'est un manque de soignants
c'est pas presque Geir c'est presque pas
à moi c'est pas un problème de budget
c'est aujourd'hui c'est un problème de
soignant c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
postes aujourd'hui qui sont vacants et
qui signent n'était pas vacances
permettrait effectivement aux hôpitaux
d'être
moins en tension qu'ils ne sont et aux
personnel et hospitaliers d'être moins
effectivement dans la l'état de fatigue
dans lequel ils sont parce que cet état
de tension il repose aussi sur le fait
que avec 30% de poste de médecins non
pourvu et bien évidemment c'est ceux qui
sont au front qui font le boulot de ceux
qu'on peut pas recruter parce qu'ils
sont sous considérés et que donc ça
devient une question de budget aussi
quand on voit quand on additionne
effectivement tout ce que sont les
déserts médicaux le manque de de de
médecins libéraux le manque de médecin
dans les hôpitaux etc il y a malgré tout
un problème démographique alors
peut-être les gens sont partis parce que
pour faire autre chose ouvrir des
restaurants ou
profiter de la vie ailleurs mais je
pense pas que massivement ce soit le cas
ce soit le cas c'est qu'effectivement on
a pendant des années manqué de de
faute qui fait qu'on a pas assez formé
et aujourd'hui on le retrouve chez les
médecins on le retrouve chez infirmières
infirmières les aides soignants enfin
dire à tous les étages il y a des
pénuries d'informations aujourd'hui
enfin voilà donc à tous les étages du
système de santé il y a des pénuries
démographiques qui pèsent et donc
l'hôpital et ben écoutez si un pic de de
de de de chaleur si effectivement des
événements qui sont difficiles l'hôpital
va à nouveau être mis en extrême tension
mais à l'arrivée ça tiendra dans des
conditions qui seront parfois désolantes
mais ça tiendra le covid de l'hôpital la
tenue bon dans les conditions qui
parfois étaient extrêmes pour les
personnels extrêmes mais néanmoins bon
il faut espérer que ça tienne est-ce que
ça tiendra ou est-ce qu'il y a des
Français qui ne seront pas soignés cet
été ou qui seront mal soignés parce que
l'hôpital ne sera pas à même d'absorber
on a déjà eu une surmortalité l'année
dernière à peu près de 50 000 bon là
tout le monde met la poussière sous le
tapis pour pas trop savoir pourquoi on a
eu 50 000 morts de plus soit on attribue
ça à un bout de canicule un bout de
grippe bon peu importe non non il y a un
problème maintenant vraiment ce que
vient de dire monsieur Valtou est juste
il y a un problème sur l'accès aux soins
qui est évident
prenons dans l'ordre ce que vous avez
évoqué déjà les personnels en effet il y
a un sujet salaire il y a un sujet de
salaire le pouvoir d'achat d'une
infirmière aujourd'hui est inférieure au
pouvoir d'achat d'une infirmière dans
les années 80-1 c'est des chiffres
donnés par la CGT et les syndicats bon
donc déjà et on le voit nous avec juste
le logement des personnels dans les
grandes villes pas seulement Paris dans
les grandes villes où une infirmière
avec son salaire elle peut pas se loger
donc d'un coup ils habitent de plus en
plus loin l'essence a augmenté la
circulation pour bah venir à vélo de 50
km de Paris c'est impossible je vous le
rassure d'accord donc terminé ils
veulent plus venir travailler donc parce
que le logement et vous avez tout ça qui
est lié vous pouvez décliner ça sur
l'ensemble des catégories
socioprofessionnelles bon quand il y a
eu le Ségur ils ont augmenté à peu près
de 190 euros bon on nous disait six mois
avant que c'était impossible le covid
pouf là c'était possible
vous avez des efforts salariaux qui sont
demandés par les personnels ils ne
veulent pas ils veulent pas le faire
donc du coup vous
le personnel vient pas de ça ça c'est
pour le le personnel dit non médical qui
est tout médical mais on appelle nos
médicaments pour personnel médical
l'attractivité au niveau et c'est pour
ça que nous sommes en grève lundi
le Ségur nous a fait perdre deux années
de de d'ancienneté premièrement
deuxièmement la revalorisation de la
permanence de soi alors ça c'est
intéressant parce que le gouvernement
quand il y a une Ségure a dit il faut
valoriser la permanence de soins pour
redonner un équilibre par rapport au
monde libéral qui soit dit en passant
quand ils font une garde son palier 5 à
10 fois plus que les médecins
hospitaliers et défiscalisé et
défiscaliser ça c'était un accord de
2008 donc ça leur fait quand même une
prime entre 40 000 et 70 000 euros par
an bon voilà
nous on n'a pas ça dans le service
public quand on a travaillé pour le
covid on a bien travaillé on a tout
redonné aux impôts en fait oui parce
qu'on a changé de trans on a tout
redonné bon ça a donné une mauvaise
ambiance donc du coup il y a un problème
sur l'attractivité des médecins
hospitaliers après vous avez bien sûr
les trucs caricaturaux mais les
anesthésistes réanimateurs on en forme à
peu près 475 par an 75% parc dans les
cliniques privées parce qu'ils gagnent
beaucoup plus d'argent bon et donc après
vous avez le le financement et les
hôpitaux et là c'est vrai si vous voulez
qu'on est allé trop loin sur les
fermetures puisque maintenant on est en
dessous des moyennes sur les lits
médicaux chirurgicaux et obstétricaux et
ça ça pose vraiment
problème et je pense que justement à mon
idéal qui consistait à dire on va
pouvoir maintenir les personnes âgées
chez elles etc en fait on n'a pas eu la
structuration pas le niveau pas la
formation des personnels et nous quand
on voit ce qui se passe dans les EHPAD
notamment
voilà mais il y a un chantier alors en
même temps c'est bien il y a un chantier
énorme mais c'est c'est vraiment c'est
cataclysmique en fait
un autre chez d'inquiétude c'est la loi
riste un mot de réponse
on le sait depuis depuis longtemps voilà
c'est si tu as de santé c'est un
paquebot entre le moment où on donne un
coup de barre et le moment où on va voir
le paquebot comment ça bouger dans la
bonne direction il va se passer
malheureusement quelques années ne
serait-ce que ce sont parce que ce sont
les années de formation après
effectivement il y a un problème de de
financement
et les pistes là aussi seront sont
posées vous voyez mais je sais que vous
connaissez aussi bien le sujet que moi
mais voyez quand vous avez un professeur
qui est à Necker très bien et qui fait
un rapport à l'Académie de médecine qui
sert strictement à rien et qui dit il
faut fermer 150 maternités encore et que
d'un coup vous avez la direction de
l'organisation et des soins du ministère
qui nous convoque en disant bah écoutez
c'est super les urgentistes maintenant
vous allez faire les accouchements à
domicile on leur a dit non d'accord et
donc à chaque fois on est en train de de
trouver des solutions à la petite
semaine qui montre et là où vous faites
le raccord avec ce qui se passe
actuellement maintenant dans le pays qui
est en train de d'exploser c'est parce
que on abandonne les gens on abandonne
les gens et moi c'est sans arrêt ou
maintenant on arrive chez des gens qui
n'ont plus de soins il y a plus de
médecins qui vient à domicile il y a les
médecins traitants vous avez 600000
personnes dans l'affection du rection
pas de médecin traitant etc et donc les
Français sont sympas parce que on leur
dit il faut des médecins traitants ils
cherchent des médecins traitants mais il
y en a pas donc voyez l'abandon du truc
et alors c'est c'est vraiment c'est du
jamais vu en fait il y a un autre sujet
d'inquiétude c'est la loi rice Mathias
vous êtes allé voir les conséquences de
cette loi du côté de Bourg-en-Bresse
avant de voir votre reportage dites-nous
un mot de ce qu'est cette Loris elle est
appliquée depuis le 3 avril dernier son
objectif et notamment d'encadrer la
rémunération des médecins intérimaires
dans les hôpitaux publics qui te seront
dorénavant 1400 euros brut maximum pour
une garde de 24 heures alors c'est des
mesures pour
éviter les dérives du système mais
derrière ce recadrage pour certains il y
a aussi des inquiétudes dans des centres
hospitaliers souvent ruraux ou
périurbain sur leur capacité d'attirer
des médecins c'est le cas à
Bourg-en-Bresse où je me suis rendu
alors pour l'heure la direction l'assure
il n'y aura pas de risque de fermeture
totale éventuellement partielle mais
c'est notamment dû à une réorganisation
sur le département
ici on retrouve une zone d'attente pour
les patients qui une fois qu'ils ont été
examinés sont en attente d'examen soit
une imagerie soit même leurs résultats
de prise de sang comme ça ils sont quand
même surveillés par le personnel et puis
dès qu'il y en a tous les résultats on
les réinstalle et puis on conclut les
patients soit pour une orientation vers
un retour à domicile soit vers une
hospitalisation au centre hospitalier de
Bourg-en-Bresse les urgences tournent à
plat régime avec en moyenne plus de 48
000 passages par an le service est sur
l'accord de raid d'autant plus que
depuis l'application de la loi Rist et
le plafonnement de la rémunération des
intérimaires les effectifs sont en
partie amputés on a vu disparaître ces
médecins intérimaires qui
n'interviennent plus dans le service et
donc il y a effectivement fallu qu'on se
réorganise avec déjà un investissement
un peu plus important des médecins
titulaires qui font du temps additionnel
en quantité non négligeable et puis des
réorganisations au niveau au niveau du
du système pour pouvoir
recevoir les patients et les accueillir
dans les bonnes conditions avec 20
médecins équivalent en plein le service
du docteur roux est déjà sous calibré là
où 30 médecins seraient nécessaires en
plus des urgences la radiologie et
l'anesthésie sont également touchés
pourtant la direction la sur il ne
devrait pas y avoir de fermeture de
service à Bourg-en-Bresse mais peut-être
sur d'autres sites du département qui
dépendent directement du centre
hospitalier on peut avoir des fermetures
partielles c'est-à-dire notamment sur la
nuit parce que voilà on a des
difficultés à pourvoir ces postes là on
maintiendra le Semur et derrière on
proposera collectivement une
communication patient pour leur dire
voilà vous pouvez néanmoins de se rendre
par exemple dans votre établissement et
vous serez réadressé soit vers la
médecine de ville si votre situation ne
concerne pas une prise en charge des
urgences soit vers de la
téléconsultation soit même vous serez
adressé vers un service d'urgence si
votre situation l'exige mais le problème
n'est pas propre à la région en réalité
c'est une grande partie des villes
moyennes qui voit leur offre de soins
réduite à peau de chagrin pour
Jean-François debat maire de
Bourg-en-Bresse et président délégué de
ville de France cette carence médicale
ne doit pas justifier tous les excès en
matière de rémunération qu'il y ait
quelques fermetures et quasiment
obligatoire simplement à un moment donné
on ne peut pas céder en permanence à un
chantage financier qui font que
un certain nombre un petit nombre de
mercenaires ont au mépris de leur
serment d'Hippocrate décider de demander
2500 3000 4000 euros pour une journée de
travail et pour venir finalement soigner
des gens dans une qui en ont besoin dans
une situation aujourd'hui tendue du
point de vue de la démographie médicale
cette attitude n'est pas acceptable avec
quelques dix mille praticiens
intérimaires aujourd'hui en France selon
le syndicat national des médecins
remplaçant des hôpitaux c'est près de
300 services qui pourraient être menacés
de faire mais cet été
Patrick Pelou elle était nécessaire
cette loi pénalise les hôpitaux
vous ne pouviez pas continuer à avoir un
dumping financier qui en plus de ça moi
j’avais des collègues du service public
il faut comprendre on leur proposait en
effet le maire a raison c'est on leur
posait 4000 5000 euros pour aller faire
24 heures dans des ce n'était pas
possible on ne pouvait pas continuer
comme ça je comprends les collègues qui
faisaient ça mais ce n'était pas
possible et c'est là où il fallait le
faire alors moi je pense si vous voulez
enfin ça a été notre analyse qu'il
fallait revaloriser les gardes et la
permanence de soins pour les médecins
hospitaliers pour vraiment au moins
avoir une égalité avec la rémunération
qu'il y a dans le secteur libéral bon ça
n'a pas été fait je sais pas où on en
est les discussions sont arrêtées pour
l'instant c'est pour ça qu'on est en
grève lundi mais il fallait il fallait
encadrer ça ça c'est évident et vous
savez déjà 1400 bruts
par rapport aux 270 plus le temps de
travail que nous avons nous c'est encore
c'est encore généreux oui sincèrement
oui non mais c'était un cancer pour
l'hôpital et pour cette affaire
d'intérim enfin certains ont poussé
effectivement dans des dans des
comportements de comme le disait
Jean-François debat le maire de
Bourg-en-Bresse dans des comportements
de mercenaires ou finalement on allait
au plus offrant et on
faisait son marché quoi donc c'est c'est
ça ça amenait des comportements enfin
moralement moralement il était urgent
qu'on mette un stop à cette à cette
dérive qui au-delà du problème financier
parce que ça représente un coût énorme
oralement était pas sain de faire
cohabiter dans le même service des gens
qui parce que ils étaient intérimaires
étaient gagnés 4 5 6 fois plus que le
praticien hospitalier qui essayait de
tenir à bout de bras sa présence dans le
service c'est pas logique vous pensez
que ça va se résorber du coup ces
médecins intérimaire qui pour l'instant
joue la politique de la chaise vide il
joue pas à la politique de la chaise je
pense que les choses vont vont se
remettre sont recalés effectivement il
faut arriver et à à avayer aussi à ce
que certains ne soient pas obligés
malgré tout de signer des contrats qui
de manière un peu détournée permettrait
quand même d'offrir des rémunérations de
ce type il y a le rôle des sociétés
d'intérim aussi qui poussent à la roue
qu'il faut sans doute arriver à réguler
aussi voilà c'est c'est un ensemble qui
doit jouer mais en tous les cas
aujourd'hui ce plafonnement moi je
souhaite vraiment qu'il soit respecté de
manière drastique drastique par les
comptables publics parce que finalement
les comptes publics c'est eux qui
versent les sommes c'est pas les
Hospitaliers ils sont pas des des
ordonnateurs publics donc il est
comptable public doivent veiller à ne
pas accepter des contrats qui ne
seraient pas dans le dans les clous de
de ce qu'est aujourd'hui la loi et il
faut le sujet votre question est très
juste parce que le sujet il va il va
au-delà notamment il va falloir un
moment c'est une suggestion que je fais
à Monsieur le Député il faut
déverrouiller le blocage qu'il y a au
niveau des centres universitaire qui
garde les internes qui gardent les
médecins et probablement
trop lentement ou d'un coup je les
connais vous les connaissez comme moi
nos chers chapeaux à plumes
d'universitaires ils veulent garder les
ailiers tout sur des armes moi je
reprends le discours du président de la
République à Marseille il lui a dit il y
a pas que l'université et l'université
c'est pas forcément l'élite d'accord
c'est ce qu'a dit le président de la
République moi je l'écoute très bien
mais ça veut dire si vous voulez que si
vous cassez le verrouille le blocage
qu'il y a entre les centres hospitaliers
et les hôpitaux de proximité alors il y
a déjà des mesures qui ont été mises en
place mais il faut les redynamiser c'est
les primes
multi-sites etc c'est avec ces éléments
là qu'on peut faire qu'on peut faire
quelque chose et pour améliorer la
situation de l'hôpital il faut lutter
contre les déserts médicaux et c'est
l'objet d'un texte que vous avez porté
Frédéric Walton va en dire de vos
Mathias c'est ça la proposition de loi
Val tout qui vient donc de passer en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
et qui devrait arriver
à l'automne au Sénat alors une
proposition de loi qui vise à apporter
des solutions
urgentes et nécessaires pour faire face
à la crise du système de santé alors
parmi vos propositions il y a la
création d'un indicateur territorial de
l'offre de soins qui devrait être mise à
jour tous les deux ans la facilitation
d'exercice aussi pour les médecins
étrangers interdire l'intérim pour les
professionnels médicaux en début de
carrière limiter les aides à
l'installation à une fois tous les 10
ans et enfin contraindre les hôpitaux et
les cliniques privées à participer à la
permanence de soins c'est un texte vaste
ambitieux même vous avez dynamité le
paysage médical
certains me disent que ça va passer loin
d'autres cris à la mort de la médecine
libérale donc je me dis que la vérité
doit être entre les deux et donc
finalement on a sans doute mis le doigt
sur certaines des solutions alors c'est
pas une solution miracle parce que en
l'occurrence sur ces sujets là il faut
être modeste il y a pas de solution
miracle on essaie de faire bouger
quelques lignes quand vous dites obliger
les hôpitaux et les cliniques à
participer à la permanence des soins non
c'est obligé d'être cliniques à
participer et donc les médecins et les
spécialistes libéraux à participer à la
permanence des soins parce que quand
tout à l'heure
juste titre à radiologue qui va bosser
dans le privé non seulement il est payé
3-4 fois plus mais en même temps il a
pas les contraintes des gardes bon ben
dorénavant il aura les contrats des
gardes peut-être l'affaire du salaire
sera toujours celle de la rémunération
ça a toujours celle-là mais au moins il
y aura la contrainte des gardes
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui là où les
cliniques existent il est pas logique
que ce soit le seul hôpital qui assume
la permanence des soins en établissement
87% aujourd'hui la permanence des soins
en établissement si les hôpital qui de
le portent 13% les clinique bon bah on
sera peut-être pas à jamais à 55 ans
dans tous les cas on va rééquilibrer ça
de manière à ce que toutes les forces
médicales quel que soit le statut du
praticien du médecin soit mise à
contribution après 20 heures la nuit le
week-end et les jours fériés il y a
voilà donc on progressivement on fait
bouger les lignes on aurait pu sans
doute aller aller plus loin parce que là
tout à l'heure depuis tout à l'heure on
parle de la on parle du premier recours
quand on parle des urgences on parle du
premier recours mais je rappelle juste
une chose c'est pas la mission de
l'hôpital d'assumer le premier recours
ou alors ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
change notre système de santé et qu'on
dit c'est avant l'hôpital il est de
dispensaire de proximité à plateau
technique à laboré alors à ce moment-là
mais c'est un autre système de santé
mais ce que j'ai aujourd'hui l'hôpital
aussi Palli à certaines grd de ce
qu'elle a crise de la médecine libérale
ça veut pas dire que les médecins
libéraux se sont mis hors sujets
simplement ils sont aussi touchés par
une crise profonde dont on parle moins
mais qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ça ça pèse
sur l'hôpital et la conclusion
l'erreur politique monstre ça a été 2002
quand ils ont oublié et enlevé
l'obligation de faire des gardes
pourquoi le service public et je suis
médecin hospitalier j'ai mes astreintes
je suis obligé de travailler j'ai des
contraintes toutes les charges c'est le
service public le monde libéral en 2002
a obtenu la fin l'obligation de faire
des gardes ça a été une erreur vous êtes
médecin vous devez participer je suis
complètement d'accord et une obligation
de participer aux gardes bon très bien
ils en veulent pas mais du coup vous
avez encore là une fracture avec la
société et une contestation de la
population
l'impression d'être abandonné les
médecins il faut qu'ils soient à
l'hôpital et je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord c'est pour moi il y a une
richesse à faire le quotidien et le
premier cours à l'hôpital public
l'Assistance publique c'est une noblesse
c'est ce qui est votre socle humaniste
de la société et le monde médical il
faut vraiment qui qui comprennent ça et
vraiment
l'accompagnement de la population est
vraiment absolument essentiel merci
beaucoup merci messieurs pour rester
avec nous on regarde ce qu'elle a une de
nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
et Mathias on en parlait avec Patrick
poudre Frédéric veltou elle a une des
journaux régionaux c'est la mort de Naël
voilà l'ombre de choc titre Midi Libre
le Télégramme ou encore Var-Matin depuis
la nuit de mardi à mercredi les tensions
se multiplient dans de nombreuses villes
de France comme à Toulouse ou La Dépêche
du Midi relate des affrontements dans le
quartier de La Reynerie ou des tensions
également à la une du Courrier Picard et
de Sud-Ouest qui parle d'une brûlante
colère en fin de Républicain Lorrain
ouvre un débat plus large sur l'usage
des armes par les forces de l'ordre et
notamment les conditions d'ouverture du
feu l'autre actualité c'est la visite
d'Emmanuel Macron à Marseille qui a pris
fin voilà l'heure du bilan a sonné pour
le Macron thon c'est le non inventé par
le quotidien La Marseillaise la Provence
se fait plus sobre en s'interrogeant
simplement sur l'éventualité de voir des
mini réacteurs nucléaires sur le port de
Marseille alors pendant sa visite le
chef de l'État ouvert de nombreux
chantiers hier c'est notamment la
question du logement pour lutter contre
les marchands de sommeil qui a été mis
sur la table et donc aussi les chantiers
du grand port de Marseille en grand on
continue dans les superlatifs
Macron qui veut ouvrir le port de
Marseille sur la ville pourquoi pas y
installer un centre nucléaire sur la
Méditerranée bref je cite être beaucoup
plus audacieux c'est ce mot on termine
avec une autre plus joyeuse on en a
besoin samedi c'est le coup d'envoi du
Tour de France voilà notre presse
régionale qui le rappelle à notre bon
souvenir Corse-Matin ouvre la malle à
souvenirs il y a 10 ans la Grande Boucle
partait de l'île de beauté pour sa 100e
édition le populaire du centre lui donne
rendez-vous au néerlandais Matthieu
Vanderpool à Saint-Léonard c'est le
petit-fils de Raymond Poulidor on s'en
souvient ce sera la le 9 juillet cette
étape et ce sera la belle histoire du
jour aussi celle de Didier c'est un
c'est le journal Le réveil qui nous en
parle un retraité qui depuis trois ans
n'a manqué aucune étape du Tour de
France à bord son camping-car il réalise
ses petits rituels les drapeaux et il
est toujours là on lui souhaite un bon
tour de France un bon Tour de France à
Didier merci Mathias merci beaucoup
merci Patrick Bruel merci Frédéric
Valtou d'avoir été avec nous merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis pour voir ou
revoir cette émission c'est sur public
sénat.fr à 18h vous avez rendez-vous
avec Thomas Hugh et nous on se retrouve
demain très bonne journée
[Musique]